[Music]
hi there this is manish malik applied
scientist at relevance and AI team
that's my colleague Doron and Nilesh and
we all work on info box which is
conversational Q&A powered by AI and as
part of that we're building some amazing
AI capabilities like understanding the
conversational questions are doing
reading comprehension to extract the
answers do inference on piece of text to
infer the answers and then do Machine
writing to convert the answer in a more
natural language way you'll see will
show you some of the demo today but you
see in the middle some of our
best-in-class
reading comprehension models and on the
right is the demo that I'm gonna show
you just now so if you look at this as
you know this is a user session where
users who's the father of modern physics
and we show the answer right here but
now we are introducing this chat button
which is really gonna do conversational
search experience so think of this as
you know Bing becoming more
conversational now because we can
understand and have conversations we can
answer any question from the internet
whether it's from a specific website or
a generic question so when you click the
chat button this window opens and now
you can ask questions the first so
you'll see that we understood the
context was who's the father of modern
physics and now the next question is
what about chemistry we were able to
understand that the user was asking
who's the father of modern chemistry and
we were able to not just answer the
question but also extract the answer and
show it at the top and with the goal of
really helping user quickly find the
information that they're looking for and
understanding their conversational type
of questions the next question is did
Einstein when Nobel Prize we were able
to answer that question when did he when
and if you hover over this Nilesh it's
gonna show that the answer was right
there 1922 and and which we were able to
extract the answer and show it at the
top and then we are also able to
understand when the question is a
conversational question or a chitchat
question or an info seeking question so
if you say are you real we are able to
do very limited chitchat you know where
were you born and then you know we are
able to also understand the switch
between when the conversational you know
when the question becomes chitchat
question or an info seeking question so
if the next question is is garter snake
venomous we're able to answer that
question and if you look at the next
question what about king cobra and now
we're not just answering the question
we're doing inference on top of it to
say that yes king cobra is indeed
venomous and if you show a little bit up
go a little bit up Nilesh you know the
reason why this is very interesting
example is garter snake venomous the
reason why we didn't do inference here
is because it's very very hard when you
look at this text even for humans to
make a conclusion or inference that you
know garter snake is venomous or not
because it says garter snakes were long
thought to be non-venomous but you know
they they have a gland that does produce
a venom so it's very hard so our model
is not super confident that you know
whether we can infer the information or
not just to wrap up I guess what the
what this demo is really showing is that
they're building some great AI
technology and working on some amazing
research problems and you know hoping to
really make bang more conversational and
really advanced the the advent of AI
technology my name is Manish Malek so
you're welcome to reach out to us
you can go to we're currently
experimenting on bing.com
so you you'll you know start to see
these chat windows open up in your
experiments when you go to bring calm
but we are we haven't shipped yet to all
the users so keep an eye out for
for infobox